>>Male Presenter: Hello everyone.
Welcome to another edition of Authors at Google.
We're very excited to have Renee Montagne
with us today, co-host of "Morning Edition."
I don't know how many of you are actually
up at that time of day.
[laughter]
So, maybe?
I don't know.
I usually am.
So, as I'm driving to work, I usually listen
to the show.
So I'm very excited.
The book is "This is NPR, The First Forty
Years."
It's great for me to be able to put some faces
to the voices that I hear on NPR every day.
And it's great to hear some of the stories--all
the exciting people they meet, all the great
events they cover.
So, no further introduction.
Renee Montagne.
[applause]
>>Renee Montagne: Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mike, for the introduction.
I hope you, I'm imagining those in this room
probably do listen to "Morning Edition," or
you certainly listen to NPR shows, which is
what this book is about.
And in order, in fact, to talk about the book
is to talk about NPR.
But I just have to say one thing, which I
will say to anybody, I love Google.
[laughter]
And I actually, it's almost hard to imagine
living without it and doing what we do without
it.
And one of the interesting things about doing
this book, which, of course, now it's the
forty-first, this now it's the 41 years of
NPR.
When we were doing this book, like not last
year, but the year before, and each of--.
There are four decade chapters and they were
given to four different authors to do the
chapters.
It was such an amazing walk down like, remembering
what life was like without Google basically,
and everything else that's come onto the scene
in the last, sometimes five years.
The last ten, the last decade anyway.
And things like we now have--I'm jumping ahead
here, but I just wanna say--we now have, we
now have people we interview, we ask them
to record themselves on their iPhones.
And it's like something out of like, the future,
to be able to say there's a microphone and
the quality, unless you really screw up, will
be really good.
And do you mind just recording yourself?
I mean, that, I couldn't have made that one
up even years ago.
So, anyway, I'm delighted to talk about the
book because I think for those of you, and
there is, I was thinking maybe it would be
a group where nobody would've been born by
the beginning of NPR.
But the fact, some of you look like you were
born back then.
So, some of you might recognize some of what
I'm going to talk about.
As I say, there were four, lots of contributors
and introductions--Susan Stamberg, Cokie Roberts.
Susan talks about--I wasn't there--but in
1971, in May 3rd, when the show went on the
air, in the weeks leading up to that, they
had meetings.
This is how NPR began.
They had meetings.
They all sat on the floor, figured out what
the mission was and many things that they
were, as they were trying to literally bring
into being this entity, National Public Radio.
And they sat on the floor.
And Susan had told me that story once or twice
and I never realized that until she wrote
her introduction, that the reason that they
sat on the floor wasn't because they all were
a bunch of hippies, but because there were
no chairs.
[laughter]
NPR had, was that, they hadn't literally bought
the chairs yet when "All Things Considered"
first went on the air.
And so, there were these contributions by
all kinds of people.
And as I say, the four chapters, and for those
of you who have books, I'll tell you literally--if
you wanna know--what's say, my writing or
Ari Shapiro's writing.
It's the white pages.
[laughs] And then all the rest are maybe really
the best part, are these inserts, the side
bars, which are personal stories from a whole
range of people--how they got to NPR, what
they did.
There's also transcripts, which are nice.
And they picked ones that did work on the
page, but it's interesting to see some of
this stuff written down when the whole essence
of what we do is for the ear and is in storytelling
mode.
So, I'm just gonna begin with my own chapter,
which is the 90s, which is an era of NPR that
was a great turning point for NPR.
I mean, I think it's safe to say that up until
the end of the 80s, NPR was a well-kept secret.
I mean, it was, what's that expression for
when like, a few people know about something
and they're really dedicated, but the world
at large isn't that familiar?
I traveled through Texas to do a story on
a tornado where you could travel for seven,
eight hours and never pick up an NPR station.
And also through Nebraska in 1988, the whole
western side of Nebraska, you could not pick
up an NPR station.
And that all changed in about two or three
years.
There's no place you can go now and theoretically,
if you're not right in the mountains, pick
up an NPR station.
And one of the things that changed it, actually,
was our foreign coverage.
We were very, to the degree that NPR was known,
people knew Cokie Roberts.
I mean, she made her name on NPR before she
went over to ABC.
They knew Linda Wertheimer.
They knew the people who covered Washington.
And to the degree that it was known and very
respected by the time, I was freelancing at
that time, it was because of that sort of
coverage.
That and a certain amount of reaching out
to the small towns of the country in innovative
ways, because whereas we now have stations
like KPCC that have full service news departments,
in those days, pretty much we didn't even
have that.
I mean, we had a Washington contingent and
we had, in the 80s, I can't give you an exact
count, but there were maybe ten staff reporters
in the country, maybe.
I mean, I can remember there was America Rodriguez
here in Los Angeles.
That was her name.
She went on to other things, but America Rodriguez.
There was Scott Simon in Chicago.
There was, I mean, you could name them practically.
In fact, I might be wrong.
There might have only been five national correspondents.
And there was no foreign, there was one foreign
correspondent and that was, it was Robert
Siegel in a chunk of the 80s because we had
a location and still do, although it's not
Bush House anymore.
We had studios in Bush House as of, I think,
1979 or '80.
Sylvia Poggioli, for instance, I used to chatter
with her.
You had the fun of talking with people that
I know very well, but I really see 'cause
NPR, all our friends are people in other places.
You become friends with somebody that you
have never lived in the same town or city.
And Sylvia's one of the long time friends
who I don't ever hardly get to sit and have
an in-depth conversation with, but I did for
the book, which was fun.
And I said, "Sylvia, when did you actually
go on staff?"
And Sylvie said, "Let's put it this way.
They'd already named the restaurant after
me."
And what she meant was that she was so famous.
I mean, Sylvia Poggioli.
She was so part of the fabric of NPR, of the
sound of NPR, that you couldn't believe that
she was still on a contract.
I mean, not on a contract, 'till 1993.
And she'd been ten years working with NPR.
And the restaurant was this restaurant in
Salem, Oregon called Poggioli's.
There were actually two at one point.
And she was like already surfing, what's the
New York Times, more recently, was talking
about something that happened in the Vatican
and said, "Holy Poggioli.
It's blah-dy, blah-dy, blah."
It was a jokey thing about the Vatican.
So, it's almost impossible to imagine how
well NPR covered the country when we didn't
have reporters out in the country.
And we had some freelance, a lot of freelance
people.
I was freelance.
I mean, there was no hope of getting--.
I was in New York, no hope of getting a job
in the '80s because they were, like I said,
there was Margot Adler, the same people who--.
We're like, "They're gonna have to die."
Thank God.
I mean, they didn't.
[laughter]
They didn't and there's three people still
there who are were there back in the '80s.
But when they asked me to do the '90s, it
was a great thing because I had just come
on staff officially in '88.
And I, as the host, the co-host with Robert
Siegel of "All Things Considered," when Susan
Stamberg and Noah Adams left.
And I did that for a couple of years and then,
starting in '90, I started going to South
Africa.
And so, I had a taste of what are the new
level that NPR was gonna reach when foreign
coverage became one of our best projects.
And it also, the foreign coverage that NPR
provides for some parts of the country is
all the foreign coverage that anybody's gonna
get there.
I went to South Africa to cover the release
of Nelson Mandela.
One of the biggest stories of the decade.
Actually, one of the biggest stories, the
Mandela story, of the century.
And I got there the day, literally the day
he was released.
And I remember it was raining and I started
the chapter with that it was raining in Soweto,
which in Africa, I was soon to learn, a positive.
Rain is considered a gift.
And it was considered very, very propitious--a
very, very good sign.
And I got there the day that he was released.
And the idea was NPR was turning more and
more to trying to be there for these big events.
We had been there for the fall of the Berlin
Wall.
They sent Robert Siegel just the year before.
We had been there, we had people in Poland
when solidarity prevailed and they elected
Walesa as President.
We, all this stuff was stunningly over about
a two-year period, the world literally was
changing.
And at that moment in time, what was happening
was the Cold War was ending and walls were
coming down.
So, it was really a moment that's actually
almost impossible to imagine now of such hope.
A little like the Arab Spring, only with much
more, how can I say, much more of a potential
for positive outcomes, like in Poland, in
Russia.
And it was Russia before the oligarchs, Russia
before Putin.
This was like a new Russia emerging it seemed.
And to give you a feel for how it worked then,
I showed up, got myself in a car, got on the
left side of the road, started driving where
the big networks were in a four-star hotel
downtown.
A downtown, by the way, that was soon to disappear
and become very African.
But at that exact moment in time, it was very
white.
And it was called the Golden Mile.
So, all the fancy restaurants, because apartheid,
right?
Obviously, the wealth was downtown, like it
would be in a normal city.
Well, NPR had us out in the suburbs and we
were in this little hotel that was really
a salesmen hotel.
And I don't know if you know Afrikaners, but
they're like the--I don't know what you would
say.
Well, they're the white people of South Africa,
but Afrikaners in particular, they would be
out in the countryside and in small towns.
So, it was like Afrikaner’s salesmen who
were living at, were staying there.
And here we flow in and there were five of
us and we set up shop.
And the only way we could get out was through
the hotel phone system, which meant that if
somebody called you, like, say you were trying
to set up an interview.
You would call out and, of course, most people
in South Africa did not have landlines, not
just the black people.
A lot of white people didn't either 'cause
they just didn't have a good phone system.
There was no such thing as cell phones.
The political people were pretty sophisticated.
They had--what do you call it?
Pagers.
And all you could do is put your number down
and cross your fingers that they would page
you back or call you back.
But in our case, it went through a hotel system
where, if you were out you wouldn't get the
call.
If you were upstairs and they knocked on your
door and you were in the bathroom you wouldn't
get the call.
I mean, it was like, really hard to set up
an interview.
So basically, you had to go to the place,
set the interview up, and hope that they were
there when you came back for the appointed
time, or if they were there, hope they were
willing to talk to you.
It didn't hurt me too much because I was there
to cover people, not the Mandela people, not
the ANC--the African National Congress.
But when we wanted to file, I had to file.
And I'm gonna actually have to look this up.
It's called, something called the--.
What you filed on was something called a Comrex
and Vince Mews, our engineer, set it all up.
And it was one of these things that you would
do your, you would talk into it and then it
would slow--not a time thing--but they stretched
it out and then they closed it back up at
the other end, which meant that it didn't
always sound right.
I mean, it sometimes sounded slightly off
in this funny way, but that was the best you
could do.
And as for the rest, you were on your own.
Like, you got in your car and went out and
found people.
And I used to this.
I had a technique and I was in and out of
the country for the next four years through
Mandela's inauguration and lived there at
times for as much as a year.
And at all times, I just would go into the
townships, even, there are these township
wars that grew up and there was two years
and it was pretty serious business.
It doesn't sound like anything now, but they
were fighting each other and killing each
other in the townships.
And it was a strange war.
It was between the Zulu and Khartoum Freedom
Party, which was ethnic and the ANC, which
wasn't ethnic.
But this was a power struggle.
And so, these young guys, comrades, they called
themselves on the ANC side.
And you'll probably remember them from the
'80s.
Kids would be out there protesting.
And they were young kids.
It was almost like a children's revolution
in that sense.
They were young teenagers and whatnot.
They would, I would just get, I would find
somebody and get them in my car.
And Soweto had two million people.
It was the township of Soweto.
It had two million people.
It did not have a single street sign.
It did not have--.
If you wanted to go somewhere, there were
a couple of things like Baragwanath Hospital.
And there are a couple of things, but it was
this sprawling township.
And you would go in and there was like nothing
else you could do but have some local person
take you where you wanted to go and everyone
needed a ride.
I mean, I'd be the only car driving along.
And I'd look out at somebody likely and often
it would be these young guys, kids, that wanted
to get in your car.
And so they came.
But when it came time to filing, this is how
we filed.
There were two ways to file, and this one
on the whole time I was there, through '94,
right through the inauguration.
When it came time to filing, you had two choices.
If you had a really, really nice feature story
and you wanted to put it on a nice tape, I
would, I had rigged up in my bedroom a quilt
over a chair for sound purposes.
And I would sit under it.
And I swear to God, I never got it right,
ever in all that time.
And it would fall on my head all the time.
But you would put this quilt up and get down
and do my tracks, put them on a cassette,
send the cassette--.
[laughter]
Sometimes, I actually had a machine that I
could edit it on, so I'm not saying I'd always
send it this way.
I would often edit it to my satisfaction and
then put it on reel-to-reel.
But it all started with a cassette.
That was how I recorded it.
And then the cassettes of my tapes--.
So, I'd put it not together.
I couldn't produce it, but I would put the
reels together.
And then, we had an arrangement with the BBC
where there would be a pick-up every day at
five o'clock in the afternoon, so you had
to be there.
I would knock on your door, take your tape,
take it down to the airport.
They would put it on a plane along with the
BBC stuff.
The BBC would collect it and get it through
customs in London.
They would get it over to the Bush House.
And then, at Bush House, they would send it
by satellite to NPR.
So, if you wanted to sound good, two days
from finish to delivery--after you've done
everything.
If you couldn't afford to do that and you
wanted to send a piece or talk to them, be
interviewed by NPR--and I didn't do a lot
of what you hear now.
In fact, I probably did one.
You hear now talks with people, Lourdes Garcia-Navarro,
right in the middle of, not Tienanmen Square,
right in the middle of--back in the '90s here.
Back in the middle of--.
What?
Well, I'm thinking of--.
Well, she was also in Egypt, but--.
[audience calls out answers]
Yes, thank you.
Tahrir Square, right?
But Lourdes Garcia-Navarro in the middle of
Libya.
"Hey, Lulu.
How are you doing?"
And often, by the way, we do say, "Take care
of yourself," and things you don't hear on
the air at the end.
Believe me, I'm highly aware, people are standing
with bullets going by and talking to you.
Well, then the only way you could talk to
someone, which is why I rarely did any of
those kinds of conversation--in fact, I never
did--was you, on your tape recorder, you put--.
I did something.
You won't even know what this is.
You took, you unscrewed the telephone and
there are two little prongs, right?
And then you had alligator clips.
Have you ever heard of alligator clips?
They're little electrical things.
They're, call them alligator clips 'cause
they look like that.
They're really small.
You would put it on one, how did it work?
I know, yes.
I can't even remember anymore.
You would alligator clip it into the telephone
and attach that to the microphone.
No, to the, geez, recorder.
But there were, yeah, two clips and it went
into the recorder.
That's right.
Then, you would set the recorder on record
and pause.
Thank you.
You've got the idea, right?
Record and pause.
And then, you would read, which meant you
couldn't talk to somebody because the headset
is all--.
You could, technically.
You could hold it up with these alligator
clips, but you're talking through your microphone,
so the sound was much, much better going through
the telephone.
And, or you would record it and just send
everything.
Just record on cassette and just send everything.
But it never sounded that good.
It sounded like telephone tape.
You would send your tape that way, too, if
you had to.
And I mean, I'm trying to think of all the
other insane sounding ways in which we communicated.
Once I was in Congo, in what was then Zaire
and Kinshasa, and it was the very beginning
of the end of the Mobutu, hung in there for
about eight more years and five million more
people dead.
But at that moment in time, he had been a
dictator for like 30 years and there were
riots.
And so, you don't--.
Madhulika Sikka, by the way, who I should
introduce our executive producer of "Morning
Edition," she just flew in with her daughters
for a vacation and came here on the way from
the airport.
But you would like this.
We had a foreign editor.
Her name was Cadi Simon.
At the time, she ran the foreign desk and
was really building the foreign desk.
She called up once and she said to me, "You
know about the riots?"
I didn't have wire services 'cause it was
too expensive.
And also, the phone lines were so bad that
the wire services oftentimes didn't print
very well in South Africa.
So Pearce said, "We're not gonna spend hundreds
of dollars.
You just call us and we'll read it to you."
And so, I used to call the newscast and they
would read me what was of importance in South
Africa 'cause I was covering the whole country.
So, clearly, I covered it with features for
the most part and not a daily, daily thing.
But she called me.
She said there's riots.
And she said, "and they're talking about--"
and there's the fewest Europeans in Zaire
that have been there since the beginning of
colonialism.
And the reason for that was they'd all fled.
There were like three generations of Greeks
and various people from Eastern Europe and
people who had really been there for a hundred
years, but they didn't have citizenship and
people were leaving their factories and getting
the hell out of there.
So she said, "We hear there's gonna be a blood
bath.
How soon can you get there?"
[laughter]
I'm like, "Oh, let's see.
I gotta get my yellow fever shot, but I think
I can make it by sundown."
But in fact what the problem was no planes
were going in.
They had stopped all the international traffic.
So, I ended up going into Brazzaville, which
is in the other Congo across the river and
got what was truly the last, at that moment
in time, the last ferry over.
And this was, and I had to, these two Greek
guys who had fled a month before came on the
plane with me.
I say Greek, but they were, like I said, third
generation.
They were going back to see their factory.
So, it was so lucky for me because they spoke
English and I spoke French, but not--.
They speak French there, too, in the Congo,
but not so great.
And so, they were like, "OK, OK.
We're gonna get this ferry."
And they helped me get the ferry and they
said, "You better stuff all that equipment."
So, I get on the ferry like I'm like nine
months pregnant.
And they had heard.
They had some kind of walkie-talkie and they'd
heard that people were stealing everything
off of everybody as soon as the ferry landed
on the other end because it was quite chaotic.
And, but somehow, I don't know.
I they were around me and we plunged through
and we got there.
And we went straight to their factory and
they took me before the hotel.
And that factory--they opened the door and
the factory is empty, stripped of everything,
electrical, everything.
And just that deep in slippers, in flip-flops,
because people had run so fast out of there
that they ran out of their shoes.
It was a stunning sight and I wish I'd had
an iPhone with a camera.
I mean, I go to the hotel and it's pretty
much water for an hour a day.
All the reporters were put on the fifth floor--pretty
empty.
I mean, but still.
This fancy intercontinental hotel and there
were these guys walking around with what looked
like bowling balls on their ears.
They were walking around with these big black
things that they were doing this.
And I'm like, "Who are they?
And what is that?"
And they were like early adopters of phones,
these kind of things that I think people did
have in their cars in 1991.
But they were carrying them around.
And I said, "Well, who are they?"
And they were diamond smugglers, very fancily,
beautifully dressed with these.
And you're like, "Yeah, that's who has all
the equipment, right?"
[laughter]
The diamond smugglers.
They figured it out.
They needed it.
They're working it.
But for the rest of us, it was the same thing.
You had to go to people's houses and set it
up.
But one time, I tried and I had to make a
phone, I got ill and I was supposed to be
there three weeks, but I had to get out.
And there really wasn't a way to get out.
It wasn't easy.
I didn't know how to get a flight out of Brazzaville,
so I tried to call NPR.
I did call NPR and say I needed a flight just
a little earlier, just a simple change.
It would be simple today.
But then, it took three days for the phone
call to come back to me.
There was a business room and you went in
and you put in a call.
"I'd like to put in a call to this number."
Three days later, they knocked on my door
and said, which was OK.
I didn't need to get out that fast.
Three days later, they knocked on my room
and said, "Your call is waiting for you downstairs."
So, I go down and I talk fast 'cause I knew
it was expensive.
But I never knew how expensive it was until
I turned, I got billed at the end of the--.
It was like a nine-minute call and it was
300 and change dollars.
That, that, and the way I got out was it was
a little Christian flight, like a one-seater
or two-seater.
Only room for one more.
And they didn't organize it.
The hotel organized because there was no way
to get out.
There was no ferry running across the river.
So, I mean, the way that they do it now--you
hear all these stories as you're going along--these
were things that happened without anybody
knowing what you're going through because
there was no communication.
I wanted to open it up for questions.
I wanted to, but I do wanna do one thing.
I wanna play.
God, it might take six minutes, right?
You all know Rwanda, right?
You know what happened in 1994 in Rwanda.
Half a million people killed.
A terrible slaughter of the mostly ethnic
Hutus, Tutsis killed by Hutus.
So, I'm gonna play a four-minute story and
open it up for questions.
And the reason I wanna play it is it's a radio
story by one of our reporters, Michael Skoler,
who was with us, up with me or down rather,
in Johannesburg covering the Mandela inauguration--the
vote and the inauguration.
And the vote took a really long time to count
so that it delayed like three weeks what we
thought would be done in a day or two.
It was delayed right up to the day of the
inauguration.
And so Michael--.
Here's the thing with foreign correspondents.
They run into where everyone else is running
out of.
And he was desperate to get back to Rwanda
'cause he was out of Nairobi.
And I was desperate to stay and cover the
inauguration 'cause I love South Africa and
was there.
So, we made a deal where I stayed for the
inauguration, which was nice.
Anyway, he, Michael is the second one.
He's the second one.
He sent this story, very much in the way I
just described--1994--you could not have heard
this story 'till a week after it happened,
maybe three days.
Maybe.
Three and a half days.
And it's a very long, it's a 21-minute long
story.
I'm not gonna play 21 minutes.
But there is one part of the idea of trying
to explain, in a book, what we did and what
you heard on the radio and this was, I wanted
to use this because it was one of these really
stunning stories.
He got some big awards for it, too.
He was there ahead of a lot of people.
The difference between what you hear and what
you'll see if you see any quotes on the page
because it's all in the sound in a way, profound
as his story was.
And what's happened is, and I'll just do the
set up.
It's probably gonna take me two minutes to
do the set up, but let me quickly just do
the set up.
And that was that he had gone in and all this
killing had happened, but it was really hard
to cover.
It was really hard for people to understand
it was happening.
If you wonder sometimes why people didn't
intervene earlier, like the United States,
it honestly went fast.
And it was weird because it retail killing.
People were not killed by bombs or rockets
or IEDs.
They were killed one on one with machetes
and versions of machetes.
So this six-week period, these Hutu groups
managed to rampage across the country and
kill, by hand, somewhere in the neighborhood
of half a million people.
So, that wasn't really getting out very well
and at the point at which people didn't know
much about it, this story came on the air.
[plays sound clip]
>>Michael Skoler: I drove in from the north
and entered the part of Rwanda held by the
Tutsi land rebel army, the Rwandan Patriotic
Front, or RPF.
The RPF insisted I travel with two soldiers
"for my own protection," they said, though
that hardly seemed necessary.
The countryside was empty.
We passed miles of deserted villages, fields
of sorghum, beans and bananas with no one
to harvest them.
Eerie, since Rwanda is one of the most densely
populated countries in the world.
Sometimes, the car would fill with the smell
of rotting flesh and we would notice corpses
lying in a field or by the side of an abandoned
house.
Those who had been killed here were almost
all from the Tutsi ethnic group, like the
rebel soldiers with me.
Other Rwandans, those of the majority Hutu
group, had fled, afraid the RPF would kill
them in revenge for the slaughter of Tutsis.
But occasionally, I found places crowded with
people, people too fearful to go back to their
villages and homes.
[crowd chatter]
In a town called Gahini, 30 miles east of
the capital Kigali, the crowd around me contained
old women and some younger women, small children,
but very few men.
And as I asked why they were here, they started
to lift their clothes.
[woman speaking]
This woman is showing us her legs and arms.
They have raised long wounds on them.
They look like maybe they're burns.
Those are burns.
[women speaking]
And in her nose, there's kind of a crease
now that's healed over the scar and she said
that was a spear that went in through her
nose.
And here's a little girl in a pretty flower
dress lifting up her skirt to show burn marks
on her knees and legs, and a bandage.
And here's a little boy who has lifted his
shirt to show a wound from a spear, right
in the middle of his back between his shoulders.
[woman speaking]
Mainly the boys.
Even the babies.
Why?
Por qua?
[woman speaking]
In order to get rid of the Tutsi race.
>>Woman #1: Yes.
>>Michael Skoler: The planned killing of a
race--genocide.
Foreign nations have been hesitant to label
the Rwanda massacre as genocide because that
would force them to act.
But the evidence that genocide has been occurring
here is hard to ignore.
Those in Gahini told me to go to Kerubanda
a few miles away to see for myself what had
happened to their mostly Tutsi families and
friends who, like them, had sought refuge
in a church there, but who never made it out
again.
As I drove up to a set of orange brick church
buildings, I had to clamp a bandana tightly
over my nose and mouth.
The stench was unbearable.
[pause]
I'm outside the church and there are maybe
two or three dozen bodies.
In the heat here in Rwanda, many of the bodies
are already almost fully decomposed.
You can see some skulls, some backbones.
There are what seem to be women in brightly
colored clothing as well as children lying
about.
This is amidst what is a very beautiful area
of eucalyptus trees and pine trees.
[footsteps]
There are bodies scattered all over the church.
The blood on the floor is so thick it's dried
to kind of a muddy brown dust that may be,
in some places, a quarter of an inch thick.
Most of the bodies are black and then decomposing.
They, some lie on mattresses, some on the
floor.
Some are covered with blankets.
By the altar, there are probably about 30
bodies clustered around.
One is the body of an infant with the parents,
it seems, on either side.
There's a suitcase that is open and torn apart
in front of the altar.
On the floor of the church, you can see baskets,
plastic water cans, pails, combs, brushes,
sandals, sneakers, tins of food, a bottle
of talcum powder.
The windows, stained glass windows on either
side, are broken.
There are wooden pews that have been thrown
against them.
Above the whole scene, above the altar, is
a small wooden statue of Christ with one hand
raised.
[end clip]
>>Renee Montagne: Gee.
I mean, I'm even like woo.
What happened there, and happens I think on
NPR regularly and many times in a much happier
fashion, is that there are things you can't
even imagine.
In this case, too hellish to imagine.
But when you hear something like this, it
becomes really impossible to not think about
it or to ignore it.
And that's a particular slice of what we do.
That is, bringing it to you, but as long as
it took him to get this on the radio, it had
to of.
I mean, I wasn't there talking to Mike about
it, but Michael about it, but three, four
days.
I just know that's five days maybe.
He had to get out of that place.
He had to, there was just no, there were no
satellite phones or anything remotely like
that.
Computer, he probably had no computer with
him.
Probably did it all by hand on a paper.
It still was very, very immediate.
You were still unfortunately walking with
him through this space, this little bit of
hell.
This is only another minute and then I'll
just turn it to questions.
This is what happens today.
And this is from the last time I was in Afghanistan
and it's only, like I say, it's a minute and
20 seconds.
But it's actually about five, six minutes
on the air.
Seven or eight minutes on the air.
[plays audio clip]
>>David Green: This is "Morning Edition" from
NPR news.
I'm David Green.
>>Steve Inskeep: And I'm Steve Inskeep.
Good morning.
An attack on Kabul, Afghanistan is over.
Attackers took control of a building that
had a clear line of fire down to the US Embassy
and NATO headquarters in the heart of the
city.
And it's taken 20 hours for Afghan forces
to finally clear that building.
It is inside that building that we have found
NPR's Renee Montagne and Quil Lawrence.
Hello to you both.
>>Quil Lawrence: Good morning, Steve.
>>Renee Montagne: Good morning, Steve.
>>Steve Inskeep: What do you see there?
>>Renee Montagne: Quil and I are both standing
on the tenth floor of this 12 story high rise,
here in the middle of Kabul.
And not too far from us are the bodies of
four of the attackers.
There's two more bodies in the staircase as
it goes down.
We're looking around and this was clearly
the site of a huge fight.
We're told this was where the fight was the
fiercest, right here in this room.
The walls are pock-marked with all kinds of
holes from the incoming fire from Afghan and
international community forces.
As you said, the target was the American Embassy.
And looking out of one of these big, open
windows, there's a clear line of sight to
the Embassy.
It's a perfect target from this distance for
something like a rocket-propelled grenade.
[end clip]
>>Renee Montagne: I mean, it went on and on.
But that was like, not live actually, although
it could've been.
But an hour, 45 minutes before we went on
the air.
Maybe even 15 minutes before it went on the
air.
So, that, like that's 20 years right there.
No, 18.
As you can see, I could go on, but I won't.
I won't.
There must be things you wanna know at NPR
that I haven't got to.
So, let me just stop for a moment and ask
for questions.
>>Male #1: Is there really an NPR voice?
Do you all take elocution lessons?
[Renee Montagne laughs]
And, because there's a very distinctive accent
on NPR, a [ ] pronunciation of sorts.
>>Renee Montagne: Well, it seems to my ear
just the opposite.
It sounds like some people ought to take elocution
lessons.
[laughter]
I mean, we do not discriminate against people
who have adenoidal voices and high voices
and who talk with a sing-song.
And I think the difference between us and,
as I think in commercial radio, even to this
day is, I think we don't, we actually do employ
voice coaches once in a while.
But really, people get hired in and whoever
they really are is how they sound on the radio.
And I think while maybe in a weird way it
sounds the same is because I think what's
the same about is everybody has, speaks in
their natural voices.
They're voices are, I mean, I'm obviously
talking a lot faster and I know.
I don't make an effort.
It just happens.
I put on headsets, I'm talking in front of
a mic and I can hear myself, you know?
And I don't, didn't use to like that.
But if I hear myself, I slow down, but I don't
like sit there thinking "slow down."
I just slow down.
But for the most part, my voice is my voice.
Steve Inskeep voice is--.
Sometimes, you get Noah Adams, who of course
was with us from the beginning practically.
Bob Edwards.
Robert Siegel, to some extent, with these
low, deep, maybe traditional-sounding voices.
But I sort of think the office, I think what's
the same is we all sound like ourselves.
So, that's so different that it's an NPR sound.
Does that make sense?
>>Male #1: Well, I know that in contrast with
BBC, it used to sound like NPR and has taken
a deliberate attempt to emphasize regional
accents.
>>Renee Montagne: I know.
Yes, I know.
I hear it, too.
I hear it when I get up at eleven.
They play a PM at night.
They play "The Morning Show" on KPCC, so it's
like my "Morning Edition."
Yeah.
And they're going with Scottish accents.
They have some even clearly like, African--I'm
not sure what countries--but some slightly
African accents.
And yeah.
They're presenters.
>>Male #1: Yeah.
>>Renee Montagne: They're allowing, yeah.
And they didn't used to, right?
It was, what is it, received accent?
Look, Madhulika is from London.
She's from London.
When did that switch happen?
Do you even remember?
You don't follow.
>>Madhulika Sikka: Well after I was looking
for a job.
[laughter]
>>Renee Montagne: Yeah, because they wouldn't
have hired you.
>>Madhulika Sikka: They saw my name and they
wouldn't have hired me.
>>Renee Montagne: Madhulika Sikka would not
have been on the air 20 years ago.
>>Madhulika Sikka: It happened way after that.
And I think it also happened because the BBC
started going into more regional coverage
around the country.
So, Scotland and North England and those kinds
of places.
So, you had a shot at making it to the national
coverage of the BBC.
But certainly my people were never on the
air.
[chuckles]
>>Renee Montagne: But they are now.
>>Madhulika Sikka: But they are now.
And just one thing about NPR, I mean, I think
that Renee's right that a lot of our reporters
sound exactly the way they are when you meet
them.
So, Ofeibea Quist-Arcton jumps out of the
radio at you and that is exactly how she sounds
when you meet her.
Sylvia's the same, Louisa.
We do have a fair amount of Brit-type voices
on the air.
>>Renee Montagne: Yeah.
British like Ofeibea's Ghana by birth.
>>Madhulika Sikka: Like Louisa--.
>>Renee Montagne: But raised or educated in
Britain.
>>Madhulika Sikka: Yeah.
So, I think that, yeah, you.
I think that when you, if you met our radio
voices in person, you would know exactly who
they are because their voice would be so recognizable
to you.
Whereas, I think a lot of commercial television
or commercial radio, there's a voice you have
portray.
And they do try and get the accents right
when we're saying foreign words.
We agonize over that.
>>Renee Montagne: We try.
We also fix the show.
I mean, there's a first run show here in California.
It's at two AM.
Really hardly anyone hears it.
It starts at five on the East Coast.
And so, we're on that schedule.
And luckily, in a way from my area, my region.
If you really get something wrong, like even
if you mispronounce someone's name or you
get it really wrong, you have a shot at like
doing it another time--re-doing it.
But I'll tell you one thing real quickly.
People also often look.
People say that they don't look like, people
always say it to me honestly every time I
meet someone.
"Oh, I thought you'd be taller."
This happened four days ago.
[laughter]
OK.
But, or blonder, even though this is darkened
hair, so I am a little blonder than this.
But many times, people do look that way.
There was a slight mistake in the book where
they took something out and then collapsed
something and fine, you know?
It was too late to fix it.
It was actually me saying this where it was
attributed to a listener once said about Sylvia
Poggioli.
And they what the listener really said and
left me saying it.
Whatever.
But Sylvia Poggioli always sounded to me before,
I met her.
Because I met her after I had heard her.
Like, that she would have like a 1940's jacket
on and a Fedora with, and long, dark hair
swept back with a press stuck in the ribbon.
And she doesn't wear that hat or the press.
[laughter]
But she really does look like, or did used
to, when I first met her, look like a '40s,
like "Hello, I'm here reporting," like Edward
R. Murrow only female, reporting from--.
Ruth of London during the--.
And she did look like that.
She smokes.
She's really like that.
And it kinda just fit it exactly.
So, does anybody?
Oh, gosh.
Yes.
>>Male #2: I was wondering, actually.
So, at Google, a lot of us are engineers and
so we become tech support for our family and
friends, right?
So, I was kind of wondering with you guys,
do you become like a family or a friend's
news reporter source and you go to a party
and everyone expects you to do the thing you
do on the radio in person?
>>Renee Montagne: Yeah, they do.
[laughter]
They really do.
I hadn't thought of that.
I've never even asked that.
Yeah.
[laughter]
Fill us on Libya or something.
Or, yeah.
And usually I can.
I mean, what I do?
I mean, I'm second-hand, but I'm so focused
on the latest that it's good to ask me.
It is good to ask me those questions.
[laughter]
I can fill you in.
>>Madhulika Sikka: My husband always says,
"Did you hear about [ ]?" Yeah, we did it
on the show.
[laughter]
>>Renee Montagne: Yeah, did you hear.
>>Madhulika Sikka: Thanks to me you know it.
[laughter]
>>Male #3: You spoke about the '90s as being
a critical decade of transformation.
How did the intensifying congressional attacks
on NPR and public broadcasting figure into
the changes there?
>>Renee Montagne: Back then, the original
Newt stuff?
>>Male #3: Yes.
>>Renee Montagne: Seriously, Newt Gingrich
was after us.
Yes.
I had to do a little segment on it.
Who, by the way, he might not fess up to it
now, but I use it 'cause I fact-checked it.
I saw the speech that he said this in, who
said in the early 2000s.
I don't know.
Either NPR's gotten less liberal or I've gotten
more relaxed, whatever the quote was.
Oh, here it is.
I turned to it by accident.
Newt Gingrich, they tried what they called
"zero out public," well, public broadcasting.
They were, but they really had disliked NPR.
It's not all public broadcasting.
They're fine with most of what goes on PBS
'cause PBS has no, they have no strong news.
They have the one news show, basically.
And the wonderful, oh, my God.
I'm blocking on it.
The wonderful documentary--"Frontline."
But really half an hour a day kind of thing.
We're all day news.
So, they've never liked NPR.
And they used to be called in this '80s, kind
of stupidly really, 'cause it really wasn't
that--.
What did they call it?
NPR, Nicaraguan Public Radio at a certain
point to be mean, to say it like--.
And there was a little truth to that in the
early days 'cause people were really much
younger and much more underdog-oriented and
much more rah, rah, and maybe a little less--to
be honest--maybe a little less the news people
that they are today or that we have on staff
today.
But that's long since been over.
But yeah.
Newt Gingrich.
What happened was it gave us a lot of publicity.
The show version gave us a lot of publicity
and did us a lot of good because they didn't
zero it out in the end.
They didn't.
And Newt, if I may say--'cause we've met several
times--went on to say, he was on our air just
yesterday, was Newt, right?
Yeah.
I'm sorry I didn't hear it, but--.
>>Female #1: Yesterday we were the elite media
>>Renee Montagne: Oh, I'm sorry I did not
hear.
[laughter]
I was sleeping in.
I was gonna go back and listen, though, 'cause
he gave us an interview.
We kinda feel like we know how bad off he
is now because he wouldn't, has not been willing
to consider interviews.
But suddenly--
[laughter]
he's on NPR, that's like you can just kiss
his campaign goodbye.
[laughter]
No, but he said, "Listen.
On my way to work, I listen to NPR and appreciate
it."
This was in speech in 2003.
"NPR is a lot less to the left, or I've mellowed,"
said Newt.
"Or some combination of the two."
And he was a subscriber.
But it has some kind of charm to attack NPR.
It has some, it does work to some small degree,
it appears 'cause they keep coming back and
doing it.
I mean, they really, it's like a ten-year
thing or every eight years you can count on
it.
And then they don't do it.
They didn't zero us out this year either.
I mean, we were not cut at all.
In fact, we should be cut out a little bit
compared to everything out there.
I don't mean "should be," but we can expect
to be because everything is gonna be shrunk
down a bit.
But the big cut was in 1983 when Ronald Reagan,
in the early--.
Ronald Reagan became President.
He said we should not be paying for public
radio or TV.
And so, he wanted to zero out the corporation
for public broadcasting, which is the umbrella
group.
And, in fact, he succeeded.
The whole system changed.
There was actually CPB funding.
I don't know the exact amount.
But it was most of the funding for NPR was
coming from the federal government in the
'70s.
And there was corporate and then, and when
Reagan came in, he made good on "we're not
gonna fund you directly."
And, but what happened was the system changed,
so they--.
The CPB money now goes to the stations.
And stations get about 15 percent on average
of what they need to run their stations from
the CPB.
And then, some percentage of money comes to
us.
So, one of the, comes to NPR.
Well, they have to buy NPR shows because if
they didn't run NPR shows, they'd make less
money from listeners because listeners tune
in to hear NPR shows.
I mean, it's a simple dynamic.
So, it's a good deal all around.
But when they talk about defunding NPR, they're
never really defunding NPR per se because
it was long ago, 30 years ago, that direct
cash went away, really.
And now, it's just that it could hurt stations
a lot, especially small stations and struggling
stations.
So, but it still seems to be a thing to like,
hang over.
It's sort of a [ ] thing.
>>Male #4: What was your take on SNL's "Schweddy
Balls" episode?
[laughter]
>>Renee Montagne; Oh, I--.
>>Male #4: Basically they're ridiculing the
extreme effete-ism of NPR.
>>Renee Montagne: Yeah.
You know, how can you not love being on Saturday
Night Live and being made fun of?
I don't know.
The funniest one is the, was the food show.
And that wasn't even NPR.
That was KCRW, originally.
What was it, "Good Eats?"
What's it been called?
"Good Food."
It wasn't us at all.
It was the station, but people, media--.
What do you call the--?
The SNL people who live out here, who would've
heard KCRW, picked it up at some point.
And then I guess they were on PBS, too, which
I certainly missed it, the TV part.
Well, you know?
Schweddy Balls.
[laughter]
It's not a very accurate--.
But it, you know.
So, we have some funny, there's some funny
ads they've done for us.
Ads, not ads.
There's some funny funders that they've done,
done for the system that you hear sometimes.
So you can only thank them.
Let's just put it that way.
So, thank you all very much for having me.
[applause]
It's really a pleasure.
And if I may, can I just quickly introduce
two of the--.
Shannon Rhodes, who's our editor here in Los
Angeles, and Nina Gregory, who's our other
editor here in Los Angeles.
Nina and I, like I said, we get to work at
midnight every night and we're there for the
long haul.
And so, especially--.
And, of course, I introduced Madhulika.
It's really a pleasure for us
to be here.
[applause]